Today we have a proposal from Bernie Sanders
that is an area where he really stands out
in the democratic field.
It's his plan to get money out of politics.
Now, let's set up the conversation.
We've been having a practical discussion here
on this show for a while now about Bernie
versus Warren on accepting corporate and PAC
money.
Now, both Bernie and Warren have turned it
down in primaries.
Elizabeth Warren has said she would accept
it in the general election saying she doesn't
believe in unilateral disarmament and if this
is the way to win, she thinks we are better
off with her accepting that money and winning
rather than turning it down and losing and
seeing Donald Trump reelected.
Bernie has said he would not accept that money
in the general election and this has become
a sort of battleground on the issue of campaign
finance reform.
Now I want money out of politics, period.
I don't have to qualify it in any other way.
Money in politics is a toxic and corrosive
force.
It needs to be done away with.
It needs to be removed.
It needs to be reformed and I do believe that
it is a conversation to have about whether
by unilaterally disarming in the general election,
you risk losing the election and whether it
is shortsighted in the sense that by getting
into office, if you accept that money in the
general, you might then be able to change
the system.
Now, this is a theoretical conversation.
I'm not looking to fight anyone over it.
There are reasonable positions to be had on
both sides.
Uh, but I still think that if you win, you
have to work to get rid of campaign of money
in politics and to change and fix campaign
financing.
I don't know that Elizabeth Warren would do
that, but this is a very specific conversation
to this election about primarily two candidates
of the three front runners.
Biden's certainly not going to do anything
about this.
The right thing to do is we need money out
of politics and Bernie Sanders has put out
an absolutely fantastic plan to do it.
Bernie's plan is all encompassing in that
it would restructure money in politics when
it comes to parties and conventions and inaugurations,
which by the way, inaugurations for Donald
Trump have served as a great way to funnel
money for influence pedaling for buying influence.
Uh, it would restructure a public financing
of elections, primary debate, funding, Congress,
everything.
So let's look at the details.
Number one, Bernie would end corporate contributions
to the democratic convention period.
This is already just a great way to set the
tone before you even formally nominate someone.
This is absolutely a, a great thing to be
doing.
Bernie would end corporate donations to the
DNC period and two inaugurations and individual
donations.
Two inaugurations would be capped at $500
excellent.
Bernie would make federal elections publicly
funded.
This is like the big boy, right?
This is the real hallmark of any serious plan
to get money out of politics and to fix the
problems that we have.
Bernie would get rid of the federal elections
commission and instead would replace it with
a federal election administration with a governing
body of its own.
Bernie also wants a constitutional amendment
to overturn citizens United.
That's not unique to Bernie.
Bernie wants to end super packs by legislation
and this is a very interesting component of
the plan.
Bernie would install a universal small dollar
voucher system, which would quote, give any
voting age American, the ability to donate
to federal candidates.
This is empowering people in a way that not
only are you democratizing the financing of
elections, you were also, hopefully by getting
people involved in supporting candidates with
money they wouldn't ordinarily even necessarily
have to donate.
You're making it more likely they're actually
going to participate in the system by voting,
which is a major problem in this country.
Uh, Bernie would ban advertising during primary
debates and he would put in place a lifelong
lobbying ban on former members of Congress
actually doing the thing that Donald Trump
claimed he would do but hasn't actually done.
These are the big elements.
It's not all encompassing.
There are a few more.
So here's the reality.
I always want to just talk about the reality
with you and not dance around what it is that's
going on in polling.
Elizabeth Warren is surgeon.
She has overtaken Joe Biden in a number of
recent polls and she may soon overtake the
lead in the 2020 democratic primary.
Bernie and Warren are sort of fighting for
the progressive vote.
Either would be the most progressive president
that we have ever had, but we can't ignore
that on this issue.
Bernie is unparalleled in the democratic primary
period.
There is no need to qualify it further.
Every time I say something objective about
Bernie or Warren, people email me, David,
I'm disappointed.
I'm going to not watch anymore because you
know, I'm a Bernie guy and you're really going
to Warren or I'm not going to watch any more
because I'm for Warren and now you're just
propping up Bernie.
You're a Bernie bro.
David, or I'm angry because you're, you know,
hurt trying to hurt Bernie or attacking Warren
or whatever.
I am communicating the facts.
Warren is surging in the polls.
Bernie is unparalleled on this issue of money
in politics.
And this plan is an extraordinarily strong
framework.
Uh, and to quote Donald Trump, I hope that
whoever is the next president looks at this
very, very strongly because it is one of the
foremost most issues if we want to really
fix politics, this has to be at the top of
the list along with, of course, climate change
and dealing with systemic and structural wealth
and income inequality in this country.
Uh, we are doing something very exciting over
the weekend.
We've haven't done this for like a year.
We are going to be having a one day membership,
fun drive, blowing out memberships at a historic
discount.
If you have been thinking about getting a
membership to the David Pakman show, which
is our number one funding source, of course,
get on our mailing list by signing up for
the newsletter@davidpakman.com this weekend
you will get an email.
The subject will probably be, I don't know
that I haven't written it yet, that email
you've been waiting for and it will contain
a one day coupon code to get the biggest membership
discount of the year.
We've got a boost membership.
We are ramping up for the 2020 election.
We want to be doing a lot of new things once
I'm fully recovered from my emergency appendectomy,
of course.
Uh, and membership is the way that we fund
all of that.
So get on the mailing list@davidpacman.com
major discount coming up this weekend and
of course follow me on Twitter at Deepak
[inaudible] and follow the show on Twitter
at David Pakman show